and his radio show will be simulcast on
fox nation
mr bongino take a bow sir you uh welcome
to the family although you've been a
member of the family i'm just you know
you've got a major promotion in the
family
no i sean listen it's um it's really
been a long journey i mean i've been
doing appearances on fox for 10 years
you were gracious enough to have me on
remember the great american panel
yeah 2000 all right all right that was
my favorite you have to be a wise ass
about it and attack me because i'm old
you know that's not fair remember the
great america you had the football you
had penny nance on the panel i'll never
forget it was my first appearance
on your show in pr on fox at all in
prime time
and uh you know you took a chance on me
early i know you don't take compliments
well and you hate them but too bad
you're gonna have to eat this one
so no you you really took a chance on me
early i appreciate i want to thank fox
and the management too for having you
know faith in me and my content
and uh you know i won't disappoint the
audience we're gonna bring it every
saturday
night you know at 10 o'clock i am beyond
excited it's been a long journey here
it has been all right just comment on
the overall state of things because
mark levin i can see him in the monitor
he's literally
chomping at the bit he joins us next our
mutual friend
um but you know i'm looking at all
that's going on with israel
i'm looking what's going on with china
russia and iran i'm looking at the
border
i'm looking at you know a hack a cyber
attack that shuts down
our energy supply i'm looking at energy
jobs
lost stroke of a pen and a war on energy
jobs and i'm i'm
i'm nervous for this country right now
and this guy is asleep in the white
house
sean you know you should be we are
really at the red line right now we're
at 9 000 rpms and everybody needs to pay
attention
everything we warned would happen you me
the great one mark levin and other ones
before the election
if biden did x we said why would happen
well why is happening right now we
warned them
your unbelievable spending levels and
government blowouts would lead to
inflation
4.2 percent headline inflation this
month we warned them
you know disrupt uh the the uh the the
growing energy energy industry in this
country what are we gonna have we're
gonna have a gas crisis
what happened we're having a gas crisis
now you know we warned them don't open
up the schools you're gonna get a parent
a bunch of parents
really upset who can't find a way to
educate their kids what happened
it's happening now you know we warned
them international weakness overseas
was going to lead to global disruption
what happened you're seeing it now
folks in the mainstream media you've got
to wake up this is serious this isn't
political
some of the things happen well sadly
everything's political let me
sadly but this is an existential threat
some of this stuff to what's happening
to the united states if we don't have a
stable dollar a stable economy
educated kids and a country not
constantly biting at each other
because the left wants to paint every
one of their opponents as a racist
you know i i don't know what future we
have and believe me
it gives me absolutely no pleasure in
saying that all right
dan congrats on the promotion we need
your voice thank you for being with us
as always